in solchen xy endgültig gelöst mit claus
von wagner
[Musik]
ich sagte sie das war schöne zeit 50
jahre über 50 jahre xy 50 jahren in
clubs i lon meter 50 euro ganz
deutschland hat sich gruselt bei unserer
nachgestellten szenen noch und erna im
nicht dass diese posse blasen t ihre
letzte sein sollte denn der berüchtigte
esels schindler slobodan erwartet schon
ihrer wohnung haben unsere forderung des
rates
ja die haben immer auch immer gleich
ausgeschaut südländischer typ
eine schöne zeit und das ist jetzt alles
vorbei alles wobei ja klar mit dem
bayerischen innenminister ganz ohne
verbrechen was sollen wir da machen wir
haben sie den hass nicht gehört mit mir
gilt das haben sie gehört am wochenende
in jede richtung null toleranz gegenüber
stoff haben und gewalt nachsorge ab
sofort werden straftaten und gewalt
nicht mehr toleriert das ist ein ganz
neuer ansatz hat mir die bis jetzt
toleriert naja das war der fehler
ich habe gelesen in nordrhein westfalen
sind die straftaten schon im letzten
jahr um 6,5 prozent zurückgegangen bei
wohnungseinbrüchen sogar um 25 prozent
ja ja weil die kriminellen gewusst haben
dass walter holz kommt also quasi aus
vorauseilende angst recht weil er heißt
das ist ein macher das wissen die häufig
trotz einer 68 jahre topfit hier stellte
zum beispiel sehr dynamische einen neuen
generalsekretär markus blume vor den
kinseher aussagen aus der
landtagsfraktion politisch
programmatisch sehr früh sehr gut nicht
gut war das fremdwort wasser gesucht hat
aber am meisten freue ich mich auf
seinen masterplan für schnellere
abschiebung also der asylbewerber kommt
jetzt zu heißt es im koalitionsvertrag
erst mal in ein sogenanntes anker
zentrum da wird dann solange an gesperrt
untergebracht bis sein antrag endgültig
abgelehnt ist ein geprüft ist raso
zentren wie die in münchen und
ingolstadt genau wo man neulich
rechtsanwälte von amnesty nicht zu den
flüchtlingen gelassen und zwar mit der
hervorragenden begründung ich zitiere
damit die flüchtlinge zur ruhe kommen
muss man darüber lachen können und das
ist jetzt der tolle masterplan ja also
einen teil davon
langfristig werden wahrscheinlich in
ganz deutschland so abschiebe automaten
stehen und dann kann der flüchtling sich
selber sagt
in die heimat zurückkehren mainz haben
wir mal ehrlich zu hause sie am
schönsten
wer wüsste das besser als ein heimat
minister jetzt mache ich jetzt nicht aus
und dann servus xy rush hd mensch nach
all den jahren aber was wird dann aus
dem tollen kollegen hier am telefon
also da hat sich jetzt leider
herausgestellt diese mainzelmännchen sie
sind überhaupt nicht von hier
die sind aus mainz und die werden jetzt
abgeschlossene genau klaus wagen dabei
[Applaus]